at on découvert un dinosaure qui a été
tué par la météorite qui a causé
l'extinction des dinosaures la fin du
mésozoïque il y à 66 millions d'années
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette vidéo sur l'actualité qui
complétera certainement un paléo news
qui viendra plus tard sur spécifiquement
cette annonce qui a été faite que de la
découverte de cette jambe de dinosaures
que vous voyez maintenant à l'écran
cette jambe d'un dinosaure qui
appartient à petit en it is tient du nom
de tessé lozeau russe alors si vous
savez pas quoi ça ressemble ça ressemble
un peu à un ips îlots faudon ou plus
localement à notre rap dodon nationale
donc ça ressemble à un petit temps
nestea ce qu'est un bipède et donc cette
jambe et bien cette jambe on aura été
carbonisé par la météorite alors n'a pas
été carbonisés c'est juste une
préservation de la peau assez tout elle
n'a pas été brûlée par le souffle de la
météorite ou quoi que ce soit elle a
juste été ensevelis rapidement et la
peau c'est préserver et mais elle a été
ensevelie on va dire par la vague qu'a
causé la chute de la météorite donc ce
dinosaure est mort des suites directes
de la conséquence directe de la
météorite du moins c'est ce cette
annonce que vous avez pu voir circuler
sur internet récemment et donc est ce
que cette petite jambes de dinosaures
appartient réellement à un animal qui a
été tué par la météorite c'est là la
grande question qu'on va tâcher de
répondre aujourd'hui et surtout de dire
d'où vient cette information
alors déjà première réaction ah bon on
ne connaissait pas de dinosaures qui
avait été tué par la météorite comment
ça bah oui parce que ça coule pas de
source quand on vous dit les dinosaures
ont été flingués par une météorite qui
est tombée sur terre
j'ai envie de dire ça ça semble couler
de source que du coup on a trouvé plein
de fossiles de dinosaures qui ont été
flingués par la météorite en question
bah oui on vous dit les dinosaures se
sont éteints des chutes de des suites
d'une chute de météorite ça semble
évident qu'on en a trouvé plaint du coût
des fossiles de dinosaures flingué par
la météorite eh bien non
déjà ça ne coule pas de source non il y
a
et la raison pour laquelle on sait que
les dinosaures se sont éteints des
suites du d'une météorite c'est parce
que dans le registre géologique vous
imaginer une coupe géologique devant
vous vous avez une couche en bas avec
des dinosaures de dans une couche
d'argile noir avec des résidus de mes
deux impacts de météorites dedans donc
notamment une richesse richesse en
iridium quartz choqué donc des quartz
qui ont été abîmés par la chute de la
météorite et des serrures des genres de
bille de verre dont qu'on appelle des
sphérules qui ont qui sont en fait de
passer ces débits de verre quoi c'est de
la roche fondue qui a été projeté en
l'air qui a formé des petites billes en
se refroidissant du coup là la roche
fondue ce forme des billes et retombe
sur terre et refont ce qui lui donne cet
aspect en fait en retombant dans
l'atmosphère elle se réchauffe une fois
de plus et ça leur donne cet aspect de
glace quoi de billes de verre quoi donc
on trouve ça dans cette couche là et
après cette couche là bas il ya plus de
dinosaures donc voilà donc c'est juste
pour ça qu'on sait que les dinosaures se
sont éteints des suites de la chute
d'une météorite c'est parce que on a une
couche avec des dinosaures une couche
avec rien d'autre que des résidus de
l'impact de météorites et une couche où
il ya plus de dinosaures et où les
mammifères prennent le contrôle de la
terre on va dire donc c'est pour ça
qu'on sait que les dinosaures se sont
éteints des suites de la chute d'une
météorite mais on n'avait jamais avant
trouvé de dinosaures qui avait été
directement victimes de cette chute de
météorite
donc ça c'est intéressant déjà pour de
commencer par le début c'est à dire le
dire bah ouais non n'a jamais trouvé le
dinosaure avant celui-là qui était
susceptible qui était un bon candidat à
à bastien celui-là c'est la météorite
qui l'a tué voilà on avait juste
dinosaures météorite plus dinosaures
donc c'est cette succession là donc ça
c'est intéressant donc là on a trouvé un
dinosaure qui vient d'un nouveau dépôt
qui s'appelle le dépôt de tanis et ce
dépôt de tanis on en avait parlé dans
une précédente vidéo puisque ce dépôt de
tanis il est déjà connu depuis quelques
années maintenant ça fait dix ans qu'ils
l'exploitent mais c'est ça a été rendue
publique il ya deux ou trois ans je
crois c'était avant le
et confinement c'était un an avant le
confinement donc ça doit faire trois ans
je vous met la vidéo là dans lequel on
en a parlé on a consacré une vidéo sur
ce dépôt en particulier avec l'un des
chercheurs qui l'a étudiée c'est un
chercheur francophones qui a travaillé
dessus et qui a un qui est notamment
géologue et qui a étudié ce dépôt de
tanis afin de déterminer que ce dépôt de
tanis étaient contemporains de la chute
de la météorite c'est à dire que c'est
un dépôt qui dans cette succession
dinosaures météorite pas dinosaures
s'est formé pendant
l'intervalle où il ya météorite en fait
donc on n'avait jamais trouvé de
dinosaures là on va on n'avait jamais
trouvé de fossiles même qui venait de
cet intervalle là l'impact de la
météorite est donc ce dépôt de tanis a
été le premier à fournir des preuves
deux fossiles formé pendant la période
de l'impact donc ça c'est important
c'est un dépôt extrêmement important ce
dépôt de tanis et donc ils ont d'abord
travaillé à établir on va dire la
contemporanéité du dépôt de ces fossiles
avec l' impact météoritique
donc tanis se situe au nord des
etats-unis si les jeunes ne m'abuse et
donc c'est un dépôt qui s'est formée à
cause d'une vague que la météorite a
fait a provoqué alors comment ils ont
réussi à déterminer ça mais en fait ils
ont trouvé des petites sphérules donc
ces fameuses billes ils les ont trouvés
à l'intérieur des branchies des poissons
dont il ya une très très belle
préservation à tanis très très fine
préservation de tissus mous et c'est
donc les branchies sont préservés de ces
poissons et à l'intérieur de ces
branches il ya des super u le coincer et
ça ça veut dire que ces poissons sont
morts et ont été fossilisé après juste
après avoir ingéré des sphérules elles
n'ont pas pu venir de l'extérieur
puisqu'ils ont des opercules donc les
opercules bloque l'arrivée extérieur de
toute façon le flou à l'intérieur des
branches il est que dans une direction
c'est de l'intérieur de la bouche vers
l'extérieur comme ça donc c'est ce faire
ils ont été ingérée par les poissons
quand elle était en suspension dans
l'eau et il n'y a pas 36
je veux dire il ya qu à un seul moment
de l'histoire du monde où c'est ce féru
l'on était en suspension dans l'eau
c'est après qu'elle ait été projeté en
l'air ont suivi un parcours balistiques
et sont retombés dans l'eau à tanis dans
une ancienne un genre de lagon
apparemment ou une rivière par aman ils
disent que c'est tous une rivière donc
ils sont retombés dans cette rivière
c'était de l'eau douce et les poissons
d'eau douce et donc en retombant dans
cette rivière ils sont tombés au fond de
l'eau doucement et donc les poissons les
ont à gérer à ce moment là donc on sait
que le dépôt de tanis ses formes est bas
au moment en fait juste après que les
poissons soient morts de la gestion de
ces férule en fait puisque ces dix
férule qui sont brûlantes donc ça a dû
faire des dommages à leurs branchies et
puis du coup ils ont ils se sont mis à
étouffer puisque leurs branchies et en
brûle et ils peuvent plus aspirer
l'oxygène dont ils ont certainement dû
étouffer à cause de ça ou alors ils sont
morts des suites de la vague qui
arrivait juste après mais quoi qu'il
arrive ils sont morts ils sont morts
dans un intervalle de temps compris
entre
quelques minutes à quelques heures après
l' impact météoritique et donc
est donc ce qui s'est produit en fait
c'est qu' il n'y a pas eu un tsunami en
fait qui est qui est remonté tout
l'amérique du nord il ya eu ce qu'ils
appellent une sèche donc une sèche en
fait c'est quand la météorite a touché
le sol il ya eu une onde de choc
sismique qui a fait bouger l'eau et
c'est cette onde de choc sismique qui
s'appelle une sèche qui a créé la vague
qui a provoqué l'enfouissement de ces
poissons et donc ça c'est pareil c'est i
10 le temps que l'ombre de choc arrive
donc le temps que l'espère hull arrive
ça n'a pu mettre entre 2 heures et 20
minutes et deux heures je crois on le
sait est calculée à partir du trajet
balistique
d26 férule et la sèche elle même est
arrivé au bout de huit heures donc en
fait on est vraiment sûr voilà la
journée le jour où les dinosaures se
sont éteints quoi du coup parce que
c'est ce dépôt n'a pu se former que
quelques minutes à quelques heures
après la chute de la météorite niveau
timing c'est comme ça qu'ils ont réussi
à dire que ce dépôt c'est le dernier
jour des dinosaures fossilisé dans la
roche et il y à des fossiles dedans donc
tout ce que vous avez pu voir avant sur
les documentaires à la noël sur le
dernier jour des dinosaures c'était du
pifomètre
il y avait zéro fossiles il n'y avait
rien donc tous les lacets donc est ce
nouveau et donc 7,7 ce documentaire qui
nous montre ce ce fossile de dinosaure
c'est un documentaire de la bbc c'est ce
que vous voyez est écrit ici c'est un
documentaire de la bbc qui nous raconte
du coup ce qui a été découvert un tas
nice
donc cette nouvelle le la nouvelle de la
découverte de ce genre de dinosaure dans
le dépôt de tanis elle nous vient de ce
documentaire ce nouveau documentaire qui
nous rajoute le qui nous raconte pardon
le dernier jour des dinosaures et c'est
david attenborough
très célèbre commentateur de
documentaire pour la bbc présentateur de
documentaire pour la bbc qui nous
présente ce documentaire donc ça
s'appelle le dernier jour des dinosaures
de david attenborough voilà pour pas le
confondre avec tous les autres trucs qui
s'appelle le dernier jour des dinosaures
et qui sont ils je vous invite à aller
voir la critique de valeo raptor là
dessus
il a fait plein de vidéos il s'est très
fortement énervé mais bref voilà c'était
là c'est la première fois en fait qu'on
nous raconte le ce documentaire c'est la
première fois qu'on nous raconte le
dernier jour des dinosaures avec des
vraies preuves et là contrairement au
docu fiction que j' adore détester comme
le fameux sur la terre des dinosaures
donc contrairement à tous et docu
fiction que j'adore détester là on nous
montre les preuves fossile donc c'est un
documentaire que je vous invite
fortement à voir en anglais maintenant
ou traduit quand il sera traduit ça
s'appelle de last day of the dinosaurs
by david attenborough en anglais et ça
s'appelle le dernier jour des dinos ça
s'appellera je pense le dernier jour des
dinosaures de david attenborough
quand ce sera traduit donc c'est un très
très beau documentaire qui vous
racontent en une heure le dernier jour
des dinosaures tel que raconté par le
dépôt de tanis qui est le premier dépôt
qui enregistre pour de vrai les
dernières heures de la vie des
dinosaures les dernières heures du mezzo
lisez vous faut vous imaginer le
mésozoïque c'est la seule aire
géologique dont on peut pointer la
minute à laquelle elle s'est arrêtée bon
peut-être pas la minute mais on peut
pointer la poignée d'heures elles
servent c'est une ère géologique qui
s'est arrêtée en quelques heures chutes
de météorites dépôt des dernières
couches du mésozoïque fin et après c'est
le cénozoïque donc c'est quand même
impressionnant à s'imaginer et donc on
avait des dépôts avant ça qui s'était
formé pendant cette période donc c'est
les fameuses argile noir que vous avez
par exemple à biarritz vous pouvez voir
la limite crétacé tertiaire à biarritz
s'élargit noir le dépôt d'argile noir
très visible là-bas vous pouvez aller en
italie en amérique du nord vous avez
aussi un dépôt d'argile noir vous avez
dans les caraïbes et en au mexique pas
loin de la chute de la météorite vous
avez des dépôts de tsunami donc des
tsunamis tu
gigantesque qui se sont formés à cause
de la météorite vous avez même l'impact
le cratère lui-même qui est encore
préservée dans la péninsule du yucatan
au mexique
donc des dépôts qui datait de cette
époque là on en avait mais aucun n'avait
de fossiles et maintenant ça y est le
dépôt de tanis
à un enregistrement fossilifère des
dernières heures du mercato loïc donc du
dernier jour des dinosaures et ça c'est
quand même super cool voilà donc si vous
vous demandiez d'où venait d'où ça
venait et bah ça vient de là ça vient de
ce documentaire alors je dis que ça
vient de ce documentaire parce qu'il a
pas encore eu de publications
scientifiques sur le dinosaure il ya eu
des publications scientifiques sur le
site de tanis la première c'était celle
donc qui établissait la chronologie du
site de tanis donc il disait que le site
de tanis donc ce que je vous expliquais
tout à l'heure à propos des sphérules
dans les branchies c'est là c'est ce qui
s'est rappelée dans le documentaire
c'est la chronologie du site de tanis
pour quoi pense-t-on que le site de
tanis date du dernier jour des
dinosaures date de la même de la même
delà du même jour que le jour de la
chute de la météorite on va dire donc
comment est-ce qu'ils ont établi ça et
comme j'ai dit là tout ce que je vous ai
dit il n'y a pas besoin de datation
assez juste le dépôt de tanis contient
les conséquences logiques d'une chute de
météorite qui a eu lieu il ya 65
millions d'années donc à ils n'ont pas
besoin d'avoir fait de datation
directement sur le site assez juste
toutes les conséquences logiques d'une
chute de météorites sont là je veux dire
c'est la lecture du site vous raconte
l'histoire des conséquences directes des
conséquences directes immédiates de la
chute de la météorite donc c'est pas une
histoire de datation c'est vraiment
c'est pas une histoire de mettre des
trucs de faire des analyses d'eau zircon
ou quoi que ce soit pour dater le site
ce qu'ils ont fait aussi d'ailleurs mais
c'est vraiment juste voilà ces deux là
c'est du bon sens et c'est ça qui est
beau aussi avec ce documentaire c'est
que on vous montre les profs aussi
laisser des preuves possibles et des
preuves géologiques qui coule de source
qui ne font appel au bon sens y a rien
dit père technique dans ce documentaire
tout est déduit de vous regarder la
chose vous l'interprétez de la façon la
plus logique qu'ils soient et vous en
déduisez la chose la plus logique qu'ils
soient c'est tout c'est juste du bon
sens c'est hyper facile à suivre comme
documentaire n'y a pas de jargon c'est
vraiment super facile et savoureux et
c'est scientifiquement complètement
juste c'est juste extraordinaire voilà
c'est juste absolument extraordinaire
c'est un super documentaire vraiment
c'est rare quand je suis seul qui
connaisse la chaîne c'est rare quand à
documentaire trouve grâce à mes yeux
donc je tiens à souligner si c'est la
première vidéo vous voyez c'est très
très rare que je sois sympa avec les
documentaires d'habitude je suis une
peau de vache donc si celui là je vous
dis qu'il est bien c'est qu'il est
vraiment bien
bref le dépôt de tanis donc il ya eu une
publication sur la chronologie du dépôt
il ya eu deux publications après où ils
ont déterminé qu'en gros le dépôt avait
eu lieu au printemps parce que les
poissons étaient en phase de
reproduction bla bla bla enfin les
poissons et les plantes étaient dans
telle phase de leur reproduction
moins intéressant j'ai envie de dire
comme publication moi j'attends
j'attends qu'ils publient 7/10 bol parce
qu'il a vraiment cette guiboles c'est le
nerf de la guerre c'est le premier et le
seul dinosaure pour l'instant dont on
peut dire qu'il est mort à cause de la
météorite ils ont découvert un autre
dinosaure sur le site de tanis c'est ce
que vous voyez là c'est un tricératops
donc c'est un fragment de crâne de
tricératops et lui aussi la de la pop
réservées donc c'est aussi un fossile
intéressant mais je crois que celui là
ils en font pas tout un plat parce qu'il
est un peu en dessous en fait au niveau
du dépôt mais bon ça montre au moins que
les tricératops était encore là au
moment de la chute de la météorite donc
séparé le site de tanis il a ce
potentiel en fait de nous raconter
comment était la fin des dinosaures je
vous rappelle il ya toujours ce débat
est pareil en effet une vidéo il n'y a
pas longtemps sur le déclin des
dinosaures il ya toujours ce débat sur
est ce que les dinosaures étaient déjà
en phase d'extinction au moment de leur
extinction du coup au moment de la chute
de la météorite ou bien est-ce qu'ils
étaient toujours florissant et la chute
de la météorite a littéralement causé un
cataclysme donc l'importance de la chute
de cette chute de météorite est toujours
débattu est ce que la chute de la
météorite a juste d'achever les
dinosaures déjà sur le déclin ou est-ce
qu'elle a juste complètement éradiqué
les dinosaures alors qu'ils étaient en
plein essor donc ça c'est ça ça fait
partie des grands débats et ce site de
tanis à ce potentiel donc ils ont trouvé
un fossile de tricératops il parle aussi
durant ce documentaire d'une empreinte
de pas de tyrannosaure qui qu'ils ont
retrouvé préservés notamment d'inde et
ils ont aussi une dent d'un potentiel
tyrannosaure j'essaie de vous trouver
l'image voilà ils ont là dedans vous
voyez ici d'un tyrannosauridés donc qui
à l'époque ça peut être que
tyrannosaurus je veux dire il n'y a pas
trop de doute là dessus ils ont une
empreinte de pas d'un juvénile de
tyrannosaure aussi apparemment donc ils
ont les moyens de reconstituer la
biodiversité ils ont même un petit
mammifère ils ont des empreintes de
plantes donc il on est tous les moyens
dans ce site de thalys de reconstituer
la biodiversité à l'instant même de la
chute de la météorite donc pour
l'instant ça fait dix ans qu'ils
exploitent le site est pour l'instant
ils ont trouvé quand même une belle
photographie on va dire de 7
l'université donc on espère qu'ils vont
en découvrir plus parce que c'est
vraiment super intéressant quoi donc ils
ont pour l'instant tyrannosaurus
tricératops un ptérosaure
donc qui montre qu'il y avait des
ptérosaures en général tc lozeau russe
donc la petite d'idole et quoi d'autre
que d'autres jeux c'est plus un
mammifère du groupe a ils ont aussi une
tortue sur le site de tanis et ils ont
un neuf de ptérosaure ça c'est quand
même pas mal ça vous montre la qualité
de la préservation sur ce site on est
sûr de la préservation de type la guerre
stadt quoi avec l'oeuf de ptérosaure
dont vous pouvez voir ici la limite
voyez la limite entre la roche et l'oeuf
est assez net ici quand ils ont passé au
scanner disons ici le crâne voilà la
colonne vertébrale
ici les eaux des membres et des côtes là
qu'ils sont tous entremêlées et donc à
l'intérieur vous avez l'embryon du ppte
et rose or qui est préservée donc ils
ont quand même un truc assez ou face à
nice 1 c'est quand même quand même une
photographie de la diversité qui est
quand même pas mal du tout et ils disent
que le petit embryon ils peuvent pas
vraiment l'identifier cet embryon mais
il a quand même un très long cou ce qui
est une signature des as d'art quitte
donc les ptérosaures classique j'ai
envie de dire de la fin du crétacé donc
là on a ce site de tanis qui est
vraiment assez exceptionnel pour ça et
on qu'ensuite le documentaire vous
raconte le dernier jour des dinosaures
les vingt dernières minutes du
documentaire c'est vraiment juste
raconter le dernier jour des dinosaures
du point de vue
de ce site de tanis donc basée sur les
preuves fossilisés sur le site de tanis
et c'est peut-être justement là qu'on va
commencer un petit peu dans les mauvais
points parce qu'évidemment même si j'en
sens ce documentaire il n'est pas
complètement dépourvu de critiques il ya
eu des critiques formulées sur le
documentaire la première c'est que ben
le documentaire vous raconte laideur le
dernier jour des dinosaures du point de
vue uniquement d'un seul site en même
temps il y en a pas d'autre donc mais on
est bien d'accord que il ya qu un seul
endroit dans le monde où le dernier jour
des dinosaures est enregistrée et c'est
à tanis est le deuxième point de vue est
le deuxième problème c'est que la
plupart des choses que qu'ils disent
dans ce documentaire à propos de tanis
n'ont jamais été publiés quand je veux
dire publiés c'est à dire publiés dans
des revues scientifiques à comité de
lecture c'est à dire qu'en gros c'est
des choses ben qui ne sont qui n'ont pas
encore été rendus publics et notamment
qui n'ont pas été soumises au regard
critique d'autres spécialistes donc là
pour l'instant on à l'opinion donc de
thé palma qui est le scientifique que
vous voyez ici à gauche
si vous voyez le documentaire vous
verrez que sa tête un mais pour
l'instant on n'a que l'opinion de des
palmas et de son équipe qui ont
travaillé sur le site et on n'a pas
vraiment vu d'une opinion contraire on
va dire de façon différente d'analysé
peut-être possiblement le site d'autant
que la position du site est tenue
secrète donc un personnes encore
d'autres que son équipe qui a vu à nice
donc ça c'est des petites cd petite
caution début des petits warning qu'il
faut mettre quand même autour de ce
documentaire c'est à dire que oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai si on les croit sur
parole bon après c'est quand même la bbc
je dire ils nous ont quand même pas
habitués à des contenus de mauvaise
qualité c'est pas comme si ça passait
sur history channel voyez par exemple
donc donc ça va on va dire ça va c'est
ça a l'air quand même d'être plutôt
fiable il ya d'autres spécialistes même
qui ont vu le fossile là vous voyez les
mains de paul barrette qui est quand
même indépendant de l'équipe 2 des
palmas paul bareigts c'est un
spécialiste britannique alors que des
palmas il vient des états unis donc on
est quand même sur des avis qui sont qui
sont pas forcément qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément à être en ligne les uns avec
les autres ils n'ont pas forcément être
d'accord ils font pas partie de la même
équipe donc quand même c est intéressant
c'est un c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant mais voilà il ya par
exemple steve bruce that qui s'est
prononcé qui est un autre spécialiste
des dinosaures du crétacé et steve
bruzac lui il a dit bon il est pas
complètement exclu que cette guiboles là
qu'on voit à l'image c'est jim hall 6
n'est pas complètement exclu qu'en fait
elles appartiennent à un animal qui soit
mort bien avant la chute de la météorite
mais dont le corps aurait été déterrés
par le espèce de seiche donc l'énorme
vague qui est venu ensuite formé le
dépôt de tanis voilà donc il n'est pas
impossible que ce soit ce qu'on appelle
du remaniement un truc qui était déjà
mort avant de causes différentes et qui
est ensuite été redéposé avec le avec le
fait que plein de sédiments et été
soulevée et redéposés pendant le pendant
la seiche je me retiens de dire tsunami
parce qu'ils emploient le mot tsunami
pendant le documentaire mais le tsunami
est la sèche c'est pas la même chose
c'est ce qu'on avait déjà expliqué dans
la précédente vidéo avec le spécialiste
qui a travaillé sur le site le tsunami
c'est un truc qui est arrivé sur le site
de tanis bien des heures après la sèche
c'est pas le même phénomène du point de
vue hydrologiques tout ça pour dire que
avant de pouvoir conclure que ce petit
dinosaure est un dinosaure qui a été tué
des conséquences directes de la
météorite il va falloir des études va
falloir que l'étude scientifique soit
soumise à d'autres spécialistes pour
qu'elle soit validée voilà donc il faut
qu'elle soit rendue publique pour
l'instant elle n'est rendue publique à
travers un documentaire un documentaire
qui évidemment de qui évidemment ne va
pas vous dire le contraire de ce qu'il
veut vous dire donc c'est pas vraiment
ce qu'on pourrait appeler rendre public
la découverte ceci étant dit maintenant
elle n'est plus un secret voilà c'est au
moins ça on peut au moins leur accorder
ça vous est maintenant c'est plus un
secret donc est-ce que je vous
recommande de voir ce documentaire oh
que oui oh que oui je vous le recommande
c'est un très beau documentaire c'est
exactement le genre de documentaire que
j'adore est-ce que ce dinosaure que vous
voyez là a été tué par la météorite
oui il a certainement il ya certainement
été tués par les conséquences directes
de la météorite mais il n'a pas été
carbonisés comme on a pu le lire un par
la météo il ya certains qui ont vu la
danse est guiboles un restes carbonisés
de dinosaures non non c'est pas ça hein
c'est juste la peau a été enseveli avec
l'animal par la grande vague de sèche
qui a ramené du sédiment qu'il l'a
complètement recouvert donc mais il n'a
pas été carbonisé par la météorite
et il reste la possibilité que le
dinosaure soit mort un petit peu avant
pas longtemps avant parce qu'il a encore
sa peau donc ça veut dire que la peau
était encore là mais il reste la
possibilité que le dinosaure soit mort
légèrement avant et quand avec les
sédiments qui ont été re mobiliser lors
de la vague et éthéré ensevelies au
moment de la chute de la météorite
dont il reste un petit petite chance que
ce dinosaure ne soit pas le premier
dinosaure tué par la météorite mais en
tout cas ce sont vraiment de supers de
superbes découvertes qui ont été faites
dans ce dépôt de tanis et on va le
surveiller on va surveiller ce qui va
être publié à propos de ce dépôt et on
espère qu'ils les conclusions qui sont
donnés dans ce documentaire sont exactes
on espère qu'ils vont faire de nouvelles
découvertes pour confirmer ou infirmer
que les dinosaures enfin comment les
dinosaures sont morts est ce que c'était
un lent déclin ou une extinction brusque
bref on va surveiller tout ça je vous
dis à très bientôt sur la prochaine
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo salut